Seawater is salty,
honey Grinker and a potential source of planets saving
fuel.
Hold up fuel. Yeah.
That's right.
We have the technology to convert seawater into liquid fuel.
Could your car use it?
Would it be carbon neutral and how would
it affect your vacation.
Plants? This is what F.
And here's what would happen if we powered the planet with seawater,
you're up in the air, staring down at the beautiful ocean below.
It's your first carbon neutral flight, and you couldn't be more excited.
Sure. The tickets were a little more expensive,
but jet setting without the environmental cost of carbon emission
is well worth it.
You think about how amazing it is that the very ocean below you is the
same thing powering this large commercial jet.
But how did we get here
in 2014,
the United States Navy successfully created liquid hydrocarbon
fuel from seawater.
They did this by extracting carbon dioxide and hydrogen gas from
seawater and using a relatively cheap catalyst to convert
carbon dioxide into carbon monoxide.
And just in case I lost you there,
a catalyst is a chemical that lowers the amount of energy needed for
another chemical reaction to happen.
After this chemical reaction is complete.
The carbon monoxide is transformed into fuel.
The U S Navy was able to generate four liters a day in the pilot program,
scaled up this seawater technology could completely replace fossil
fuels, which would be a big deal
in 2017, the U S military,
but 269,230 barrels of oil
every day,
burning all this fuel emitted over 25,000 Kyla tons of carbon
dioxide. Not only that,
but because this seawater fuel is liquid,
it could be used in existing cars and airplanes.
And with transportation being responsible for 14% of all greenhouse gas
emissions developing this alternative fuel source would help us eliminate
almost 100 billion metric,
tons of carbon dioxide from our atmosphere by the year 2050,
the immediate cost would be more expensive than oil,
but if we don't cut our greenhouse gas emissions in half by 2030,
severe storms, droughts, and famine await,
and it's probably much better to spend a little more upfront to
avoid such a mess.
There are three big advantages to this alternative fuel source. First,
the resource is abundant since 70%.
One of our planet is covered by ocean.
We already have a lot of seawater ready to go. Second,
most modern day objects already use liquid fuels.
So it would be an easy conversion.
And third liquid fuels are easier to transport compared to gas.
If you put this new seawater fuel into your current car,
you wouldn't notice any difference. It would look and smell the same.
You would still be emitting carbon dioxide into the atmosphere when you drove
around,
but because you're only emitting the exact amount of carbon dioxide that
was extracted from the seawater. Initially it's a carbon neutral fuel source.
Of course it would only be truly carbon neutral.
If the whole process was also carbon neutral from
building the liquid storage tanks to pumping water and creating the catalyst,
it would all have to release zero carbon dioxide,
which means we would still need to supplement the process with wind or solar
energy.
You see this method of creating liquid fuel is still early in the developmental
process, even.
So it's important to support new technology being created to replace our current
harmful fossil fuel consumption,
raise your voice and encourage a cleaner and greener future.
We need to push our governments to move forward responsibly and invest in
technology and practices that could save our planet.
Maybe we could raise money for green tech by charging corporations for any
pollution. They inflict on our environment,
but that's a story for another. What if.